salve youtubers benvenuti ad una
nuova recensione
che come avete detto dal titolo
sarà di videogiochi
premetto subito che la faro'
molto molto velocemente perché
e diciamo per coprire il buco
che c è immette sul concorso
perchè su detto che
teoricamente faccio un video la
settimana
porsche ha fatto una settimana
dalla dall'inizio il concorso
faccio un video poi arrivi tu
subito fino alla fine del
concorso
e tra l'altro porca miseria
quanti siete veramente non
pensavo
perché il concorso da maltempo
arrivati a
10 9 10 11 adesso siamo già 22
calcolatrice
mi hanno fatto sapere che
arriveranno quindi
sarà veramente difficile del
previsto
mi sono dimenticato prima di
iniziare una foto karaoke
trucco toledo questa parte che
faccio
ooo sempre consigliato qualche
anno
qualche utente qualche canale
che ho pubblicizzato qualche
canale
quindi
bho continuo a fare così anche
se non ho un vero e proprio
motivo per
pubblicizzare quel canale lo
fanno
per perchè mi piace una cosa di
collaborazione un po' come
dicevo guastaa11 e' una cosa di
collaborazione tra utenti modà
scambiarci
iscrizioni amicizie c'è che mi
sembra
una gran bella cosa quindi
i cani via dm
aia di saronno
lo spero si dica così
e' una ragazza che recensisce
manga
ci sono tantissimi
utenti che recensiscono manga
veramente tantissime ryanair
ieri sono un secondo me perché
una delle migliori perché è
una ragazza
lincol canale
iscrivetevi perchè secondo me
ne vale la pena
allora ora iniziamo subito
scusate se la fanno oh come
molto primo molto velocemente
quindi non metterne anche
immagini di gioco
perchè
non se non c'è tutto un po'
montare volevo metterlo giù
gioci video 2 perchè
nelle cose che devo dire su
questi giochi
lo sanno bene di uscita trovare
e quelle parti di video quindi
la faccio così hi5 recensire
sono giochi
e acquisto giocando in questo
momento veramente molto
online
e sono 3
le for the wedding
queste grande taglio
modern warfer 2
ovviamente
word of worcraft
allora partiamo con te
le folder
nel fondo
le for the end per chi non lo
conosce egli è uno sparatutto
in prima persona
con il sistema grafico un
discusso di alfa x2
qui ubi
più belli che abbia mai fatto
per adesso perchè il più
versatile il più veloce quello
che parte anche su computer
vecchi
e se il computer non riavrò un
impatto grafico molto molto
buono degli altri
disoccupazione è semplicissimo
ci sono
4 sopravvissuti
ehm
credevo molto lontane.
lavare abito - veramente in
famiglia abbia
hey jude diviso in 4 campania
&lt ogni campagne diviso in
cinque livelli 4 5 livelli
perimetro livello consiste
nell'andare da una stanza sicura
all'altra con iphoto
sopravvissuti
ovviamente il cuore di joe
quello online
giocando da solo è veramente
inutile
dopo oltre alle orde di zombie
normalità, ti ci sono 4 tipi di
zombi speciali
1 il vero
che incubi e sogni classico
sottopeso pino di bolle
c'è anche
qua nell'immagine
kia contabilità speciale quella
di vomitare sui sopravvissuti
il vomito
quelle gli sopravvissuti che
vengono ricoperti questo
movimento, assaliti da orde di
zombie
lo scopre
key quelli fette speciale che
può piegare la lingua
lunghissima afferrare un
sopravvissuto di impiccalo
finché qualcuno non lo libera
lanterna e'una
non so che è speciale
incappucciato che
appena come abilitare usb
saltare addosso a un
sopravvissuto e massacrarlo
finché qualcuno non lo libera
e il tempio
forse quello più utile
che eu
consumo gigantesco un bestione
tipo hulk
che carina.
tira le cuoia gli oggetti
scaraventare tutti ad una vita
lunghissima e.e terminare
praticamente le foto in una
partita
il culo come detto prima di
questo quello con la riga
e in particolare la modalità
versus dove 8 giocatori si
sfidano 4 fanno i sopravvissuti
e4a 1
fallo ora
indirizzo mi speciali
c'è attorno nel senso che
possono esserci tutti e quattro
insieme
ma dopo ogni giocatore. può
farlo o
non so come speciale un altro
dipenderà da quello che sta
succedendo in pratica
e quindi
per connetterti mappa in questa
modalità
si gioca a 2 ruote
la squadra una volta fa i
sopravvissuti e l'altra gli
zombie e tu ci si scambiano
quando finisce la partita
e a s e finisce la campagna ei
chi ha più punti vince
teoricamente
e' bellissima cosa stupenda
questo gioco
e' questo il gioco che ti
preoccupi giocando di più in
assoluto di questi tre
solo che
come tutti questi gioki 3 cc non
ci sono delle cose che mi fanno
incazzare massa morire
il resto del presepio
la cosa principale di questo
gioco gia' bitri la
coordinazione tre giocatori
quindi
leggi fantasy the 4 survival
mode 4 zombie speciali devono
essere ci devono collaborare
devo attaccare insieme
oppure quando riparte il culo
gigantesco demo coordinarsi
circondato spararli
un sacco di cose del mondo
pubbliche amici cantante cosa
15 la cordinazione ma purtroppo
ogni tanto ci sta
ad interim partita con di
giocatori che okok ho appena
iniziati non sono assolutamente
nulla
perchè purtroppo qua
non c è il mondo si sale di
livello non ce la classifica dei
giocatori bravi youtube - qua
le partite sono composte da
giocatore che ci giocavo a 4
anni giocatori che special lo
hanno appena installato cooper
e allora punkreas di
posso materassi casini
la collaborazione tutto in
questo gioco
e purtroppo a volte non c'è
c'è ci sono giorni che non
sanno giocare quindi
caso quando sei un sopravvissuto
album allo sbaraglio da solo
mentre tutti gli altri
no perchè se quello che penso
testo ballata per computer mi
dice finita
se qualcuno loro ridarella tropo
massacrare uccidere
e si cucina la moneta adesso
sono un po' anche rinascere fino
alla mappa.
un'altra cosa che mi è che che
ci fa perché io gioco con le
cuffie che la cosa migliore
giocare con le cuffie con
qualcun'altro
mediaset in 4 mai risolto b ci
sono esposte ovunque gioco
atlanta cosa che ci fa incazzare
e is on line circuit
non so se sapete cosa vuol dire
ce
è un termine davvero pioppo con
tutto questo vi do comunque
è un termine da nerd reggi
twitter che vuol dire
non è un plus componevano polar
rice twitter twitter vuol dire
andarsene
uscire dalla partita
reich e pulire la coppia
ercp che sarebbero usciti dalla
partita per la rabbia quando ti
amo anche la partita sta andando
male te ne vai
ma è una cosa sbagliatissima da
fare perchè
quando si creano i quattro spade
sull'ascorbato sopravvissuti
teoricamente tu dopo
2 mappe inizia a conoscere bene
sai come gioca sito come
vestivano male
ti conviene comunque comunque
vada si bene o male
di arrivare alla fine con questi
altri due giocatori fucsia tipo
tre giocatori
occt che se la partita va male
se ne va
lo so perchè puoi
magari non arriva nessuno è 3 4
sopravvissuti c'è un bottone
c'è uno un un sopravvissuto
controllato dal computer fisso
fa schifissimo ma veramente
striscio
oppure ancora peggio
dalla parte degli zombi speciali
se sembra che uno non si è
incazzato dalla sua finchè non
intorno ad un giocatore
quindi se se sei su 4 se ne
vanno via due rimangono due
persone in due non riescono a
fare niente come se tu fossi 4
pere
avere possibilità di vincere
come le trombe
e ci gente che se ne va
ma tu da sola ma perché te ne
devi andare a metà partita che
senso ha
se tu sei laura se tu stai
facendo colato squadra se ne
vanno via gli altri perché tu
la tua squadra è troppo forte
la squadra save, se ne vanno via
loro e allora devi aspettare che
arrivano altri giocatori oppure
vai avanti ma non ha senso se
non ci sono gli altri
oppure se tu stai perdendo ebay
i sogni comprende la tua squadra
che se ne vanno
quindi in tutti i casi c'è
sempre qualcuno che se ne va
e non ha senso giocare perchè
purtroppo
formentera campagna
cv 9a l'amore mezza cenone poco
per una partita online
e tanto però e questo giochi
questo bellissimo gioco la
collaborazione now c'è gente
che se ne va
sempre sempre sempre filippo tv
solutions
questo gioco fantastico
purtroppo dono l'ho preso
perchè c'è questo l'ho preso
da fuoco
non è mai capitato che ce l'ho
e il 2 uscito adesso quindi
c'è adesso uscito da un pò
però
e' uscito tipo in contemporanea
questo perché il tempo brutto
colpo.
l'altro giorno che voglio
recensire motivo per cui
premettendo che io sono un fan
sfegatato di mondo il volo di
icaro chiudi in generale
e mi piacciono tutti i giochi
l'unico che non ho provato il
terzo ma il terzo perché uno
non è fatto dalla infinity word
shelter attori veri e propri
e tu perchè mi sembra ci sono
abbastanza sicuro
non vorrei sbagliarmi che per pc
non riuscito
il lettere arezzo
è uscito su un percorso quindi
io ci ho giocato al primo
secondo
oh mother moster 1 e modern
warfer 2
questo
scuola allora
questo gioco
la campagna offline
chiedo delle più belle che
abbia mai visto insieme al primo
modello offre la campagna uff
line e' bellissima stupenda
ci ha una storia dell'isola
l'unica pecca è che dura
questa mi sembra tu intendi più
belle di quelle di un del primo
modern warfre però
e comunque poco per quanto e'
bella
purtroppo buco si dovrebbe
durare all'infinito una storia
incredibile
soprattutto la grafica di questo
gioco ma qual è il tuo pc gira
siete invitati si fa
anche se proprio
non a livelli stratosferici
protestato specifero a comporre
musica
stupenda
che gestisce il tantissime cose
su schermo
easyjet leggi dispiace
io continuo a un computer della
nasa un poke da 19 anni mijo
altino non tantissimo
tutti i dettagli al massimo
in moto fluidi smettessero
l'unica cosa importante i giochi
perchè molto spesso fanno dei
giochi con una grafica target
hip hop
ma se mass effect
consolgame non è in te
su console va bene
ma su pc io non l'ho preso su pc
mass effect
. c è anche su uno
sul mio computer bollenti
spiriti pesante ce
quando si stabilizza va bene ma
quando che ne so
scarica la mappa le coccinelle
caricare ancora alcuna rete
alcune grafiche e del livello
le texture della precarietà è
un sacco di roma perché si vede
che è pesante questo 1
parliamo sempre della componente
online
due cose
da di vendola in puglia
e l'anno
lei emissioni in cooperativa che
purtroppo non sono riuscito
ancora a fare perché questo
c'è un solaio tra quelli tra le
persone costo
questo ce l'ho solo io quindi
nonononono progettato come solo
perchè anche x honey 2 celle il
geco predica sarebbero mi sembra
due persone che devono
affrontare un annuncio sul 2
quindi basterebbe anche esposte
motu proprio computer pro più
vecchio del mio quindi ma molto
più vecchio del mio
quindi non di parte
ma manco morire
fino all'anno non c'ho mai
giocato perchè passerebbe
collaborazione anche qui
con le cuffie eccetera parlarsi
eheh
giocarci da solo non ha senso
con il bot
l inter
l'altro è il online è normale
allora accendi una cosa
tralasciando le for the drum
machine for vede che non è
la classica linea tutti contro
tutti
e tecnici a squadre cattura la
bandiera cile per acqua
photo paint
down. late show pop i livelli
dopo aver giocato molto
coperture
tutti gli altri giochionline
non mi piacciono più
brian tournament 3
chiami attori ci son cresciuto
con la tua parte stupendo
bellissimo
munari e' abbastanza carino
però
dopo aver giocato modern warfre
ripeto
questi giochetti in questo
genere non hanno più senso per
me perchè
questo bellissimo q
onlinee
2 lo sparatutto online per
eccellenza per te
sale di livello
ci sono dei miti da sfatare
sblocchi garni sblocca visita
% sblocchi targhette sblocchi
simboli che poi all infinito
anche solo pers
cettola giochi 5 minuti anche su
questo locale una tangente
benissimo cecchino voglio
giocare tantissimo
ci sto giocando ci sto giocando
a pian piano non tantissimo ho
anche altre cose da fare.
ma soprattutto sali di livello
è una cosa importante
tra virgolette nel online
salire di livello 100 sei donna
al non ha molto senso giocare
così giusto per arrivare primo
e poi basta
per prima era così val di sole
in modo molto 2 secondo me
queste sono opinioni mia
non succede ovviamente molto
più divertenti giocarci con un
clan
perchèèè coordinazione in me
4 e 5 tutti con le cuffie
diverte può esser diverte
ma anche se ci si gioca da soli
non è mai tanto della scuola e
trovi sempre
una delle pecche più grandi di
questo gioco ecume fanno
impostato online
non importava quando la prima
volta mi annoiano non apre 60
quando vado a casa di mimici
camping la prima volta mi hanno
fatto giocare
all on line di halo 3 su xbox
ho visto cum erotici a cavi
elettrici cercare server in cui
giocare
non era commento i classici
giochi
cetty dalla lista di server il
numero di giocatori
lavate il nome dalla mappa
sicilia qualche modificazione
epicentro non c è il primo
inoltre erano
non ci sono server dedicati ce
l'ho server globali
she non c'è nessun tipo di
partita pulizia primo giocatore
fa tutto lui
tu devi solo aspettare che trovi
i giocatori pessimista la
partita
eh ma il cielo non piace però
detto questa credo sia
l'impostazione da console quindi
va bene io al pc
non non mi lamento
endomondo morte 2 fanno questa
porcata allucinante
i nomi dei server dedicati
anello scusate se mi sbaglio che
non si dice server dedicati ma
non me lo ricordo molto bene
comunque
mi sembra di si non mettere
server dedicati
ho detto quella porta del server
non vuole
schifo perchè
se fa schifo da una parte
perché
non puoi cavour serve il vostro
the descent of man gioco
l'hospice quello che rg tutta la
partita dire scelto dalla
da gioco taxi transfer per
rubarle
non dai giocatori
quindi ogni tanto in tripartita
ma non si blocca tutto perchè
il gioco sta cambiando opposto
crt mail aggrava ce
la sua connessione non era molto
uù
non era molto stabile allora si
giocava maradona
in più di un gioco senza
freezer ma non si blocca gioco
schermata dove ti dice
every che sarebbe sta cambiando
lo stregone - il libro karma is
a bitch davanti un miniconf ma
mi è capitato un sacco di volte
si aspetta molto ce io faccio
principalmente il tibet lecce il
tin di dati tecnici e altri che
erano petinos al differente
richiedente merci elitè cresce
il tutti contro tutti in due
squadre
il team deathmatch veterano
serie b
tutti contro tutti
ho due squadre però senza
l'ausilio di niente c'è un
colpo in due principalmente
senza pieno
senza radar senza niente
c'è realistico dei siti
possibile
esperimenti facili faccio solo
teen the exciting etnici a
veterano
clicchi per trovare una partita
prima ti devi cercare la partita
di ricerca loro buoni giocatori
e aspetti
poi magari ti crea una sala
d'attesa c'è la sala d'attesa
perché è una partita con
supporto ai giocatori non puoi
giocare solo con 4 giocatori
allora devi aspettare che magari
atv un'altra sala d'attesa con
altri. giocatori e mette insieme
decreto la partita
e devi scegliere c'è scelti
casualmente la moto acerra
napoli città caso mente
vedere i giocatori possono
essi parla cinese prova a panda
piace molti giocatori possono
dire saltatela saltatela la
saltini cambia mappa
però comunque aspetti
e qui si aspetta un bel po' tipo
minuto che non è tanto provo un
minuto fermo senza fare niente
ad aspettare
youporno tour
aspè che sto periodo che va via
cui magari don omar alcuni
giocatori se ne vanno ella è la
partita si resetta perchè non
ci sono abbastanza giocatore e
di nuovo cercare altre altezza
nell'attesa dormire
e aspetti
oddio o.o le sale d'attesa di un
poco resetta ogni minuto prima
di giocare i can down di un
minuto
e aspetti
e aspetti tu sei già lì da
tipo 10 minuti ancora non hai
giocato
io di solito le partite di modo
molte le faccio perchè
ho 5 10 minuti
liberi quitting
3 minuti controllate a pacchetto
può finire
malesani anche dire do sto 10
minuti avrò cura solo a far
partire la partita
giochi giochi
8 sentenze in 5 4 3 hanno
finalmente 2 1 palme fine estate
impossibile connettersi all'host
matura cariparma empoli giocare
in 2 minuti la scelta di
leonardo
non puoi toccare
oppure entri partita oppure ogni
tanto ti fa entrambe le partite
2 macro
212 sub alla fine c'è tuenti
se gazzi uccisioni zero morti ma
finisce la partita ma porca
miseria
perchè
quinto perchè mi importa è che
non sia gestione di nulla
pac una cosa che mi son
dimenticato
che ci stiamo don't work
siae nelle for the verde
stigma linkù books film
una delle più grandi cuochi di
carta
avrebbero mai potuto fare
io lo so perchè hanno fatto
stima
dalla pirateria c'è
e anche una roba tipo xbox line
from a proprio pc
tara in generale non prendetela
l'aletta tipo xbox vince tutto
aggiungi agli amici
effetti quando stanno giocando
politica nelle partite
case più cose
ma è un casino c'è
borgo e vorrei sapere da chi ce
l'ha. ci avete messo ad
istallarlo questo. su pc
matita per colpa di stima per
chi doveva ti posso
caricarlo installarlo basti
napoli
skynet fastidioso perchè
cerco di capire se il uno come
me che prima accusava
msn
scany port
x file includere aprirsi
testing an il gioco ci si
impalla che esplode in faccia
computer d'opera
però dovuto togliere msn ho
dovuto togliere x file su temo
solo sti
eeee fottiti suo ogni tanto a me
non ha mai dato problemi però
hai risposto io ogni tanto si
apre
perchè si per primo con lettera
toccante di stile ogni tanto non
si connette perchè ci sono
problemi
poi mentre stai giocando di
scarica gli aggiornamenti poi
una volta dopo che long
che lo aprite installa questi
giorni di un casino non si
finisce mai pieno di problemi
ed e una cosa fosse desire
fastidiosissimo apre lo so che
lo hanno fatto per la pirateria
perchè infatti modulo per due
scaricato non si può giocare
online per dire le for the ci si
può giocare in dei modi strani
con garena golf a spiegare
perchè teoricamente illegale
ebay
noi è una faticaccia giocarci
online tanto vale comprarsi voce
questo è il muro dei pochissimi
giochi che ho comprato a prezzo
pieno a tipo quasi al lancio
c'era quasi in offerta non vi
dicono proporre perché
tantissimo mi vergogno
perchè non spendere così tanti
soldi
però quello nero ne vale la
pena effettivamente ce
questo è un mondo a parte il
servizio libri cavolo di server
ne vale la pena
o o ora parliamo di
word of worcraft il gioco
più amata turi e più odiato di
tutti c'è io sono uno di quelli
che dicevano un uomo a cui
inviare un po' work perché il
gioco più bello del mondo video
sono scelte
ceceni c'è chi dice che un uomo
cattivo gioco di merda
c'è chi dice uno hulka e la
vita
non solo lo sfondo da una parte
e dall'altra perchè mi sembra
esagerato però
per me è molto porca chiediamo
il i giochi di ruolo
e un gioco di ruolo per
eccellenza per il gioco di ruolo
per e zitta eccellenza
dopo diablo è il gioco, cui ha
giocato di più
da sud a sud sono fermato
perchè anzi ci siamo fermati
con risposte perchè
non abbiamo più tu così tanto
tempo. per giocare quindi m
niente di ballo dell'esperienza
ca.
allow to work at
anche questo
allora premetto io ho un
giocatore
ha praticato in tilt. ti posso
dire i giochi di ruolo gratuiti
che ci sono
i classici
intendevo rpg
che non è una malattia venerea
è un mmo rpg soli
i giochi online
puramente un lancio i giochi di
ruolo online che sarebbero ma nn
vi è una sigla pulire massico
multiplayer honda online è
prorpio in inglese invece
migliori giochi di ruolo online
ti passa
con loro
dicevo io ho giocato tutti
giochi online gratuiti
che fanno tutti
schifo
ma tutti cn che fanno schifo
anche il tuo cuore
ci sono sempre più giochicchia
gli argomenti ci mette un'ora ad
arrivare kodak il 20 alle 21 30
c. mesi
ricerca perchè sono tutti
uguali si combatte solo
soprattutto poi i personaggi se
tu vedere un gioco presente come
metin2 che escono le
secondo me sempre quindi
evitate di scrivo youtube
come pulire il pc per me metin2
uno dei peggiori giochi
online ma infatti nella storia
dell'umanità
ci troverete un giocatore di
livello
corrado giocatori di livello
preso 60' 71 su neanche quale
livello massimo
nello 60 su quali cioè
le armature sembrano identiche
mi sembra evidente destino fa
schifo la shopper
io odio quando mi vuole mi
sembra di averlo già detto in
bikini del gioco a un gioco di
ruolo perdite in or è un
personaggio salire di livello
le armature nuove uscite nuove
armi nuovi
kia usate
una volta effettuato dalla
pizzata
lisa comodato prima fatto diablo
2 scusate diablo 2
indici gagliardi di amici erano
e di armature
all infinito
%
sono sola avete viste perchè ma
di scusa se si come faccio
vedere
sono belle le cellule
tutti i posti da vedere in
faccia delle immagini
e felice ci sono miliardi di
questa è la cosa ho comprato
delle cose più importanti che
per salire livello ci metti
effettivamente tanti modulcasa
ma ci sono 8 miliardi di questa
è la 20
miliardi
ma tu puoi fare quello che vuoi
quasi uomini
lamborgnini il cittadino giudici
tatiana questi pazienti
gigantesco modo gigantesco puoi
elenco l'espansione panico
center prato of the lich king
e impari cosiddetti crea una
nuova isola film uci gagliardo
di altri oggetti
wrath of the lich king un'altra
nuova isola è un giga liable
gli altri nuovi getti quindi
rossi balli di fila be sure but
uscire cataclisma la nuova
espansione non fosse la
prendero' perchè ho smesso di
giocarci cardinale
la grafica simulcast
effettivamente se lavezzi si
vede solo affitti richiama
picchia tra virgolette perchè
io
mmm orari pc la grafica non è
che serva a molto
io io sono un pochetto
non so se avete visto il video
di farenz su youtube
io sono uno che come fare la
spesa che la grafica non è tutt
questo ne è la prova che il
gioco che tipo soggetti può
tenere attaccato tutta la vita
e senza mai annoiato e pure la
grafica non è così
stupefacente però a me piace un
sacco perchè
perchè leggerissima
leggerissima
chi gestisce panoramiche enormi
tutta birra con lato oscuro
dipende dalla zona per sono
tantissime zone
pieni di gente
più mi dimostri piedi questi
piedi oggetti
logistica per immissioni server
va benissimo
ha una cosa c'è molti criticano
cd misto molti video in cui
veniva criticato mutuo casa
ma per quale motivazione
chi ti cerca non lo comprerei
mai un gioco che ti crea
assuefazione
q sanciti
cazzo vuol dire cioè
e' come dire
- lavaggio cioccolata perché mi
piacerebbe troppo
ma che ciò vuol dire cioè
non vuol dire niente se tu non
puoi non compra un gioco perchè
ti potrebbe tenere attaccato to
fuck che vul dire se non ha
senso di esistere poi ovvio
ci sono quelli che veramente
si schierano won't boot 80 a
giocare 80 personaggio di milu
massimo gennaro mancinante che
ci stanno tutta la vita piroso
diciamo intermedio calcio
giocato d'anticipo capo spesso
peloso riuscita a fermare la
neve sono impazzito
è un condotto in un grandissimo
gioco però
e comunque lo jogurt
non so possiamo quella linea
della realtà
niente quindi mi sento una cosa
assolutamente si salta al fatto
che ti crei associazione arci
è una cosa veloce
silvia burgio pene umano e dopo
due minuti che senso ha no io
adoro i giochi che creazzo
sezione diablo 2
era prove cmq perchè non lo
fanno per cellulare radio globo
si mettevano università lisbona
metto un po'
una delle poche cose che mi
manda in bestia di who work
la gente con cui si gioca
tutti i server che ho provato
anche io lei
le risposte o
c'è un problema allora belli
del mondo almeno 80 che il
massimo
non ci sono problemi tanto ce la
facciamo, risposta da soli ogni
tanto ci ha creato a qualcuno
per fare qualche
missione e va bene
a level 80 si fanno le istanze
che sale stacey le stanze sono
brutte di giocatori
che banca.it angela luce un
antimo sapete cosa mangiare
badoo
io uccido tutti mossi fine
arriva harbours
giudice per potenziarsi il
le armature per cui fare man
mano istanze più potenti fino
ad arrivare distance più grandi
di quelle con i pos più
il problema è che
hyundai happy travel valentina
beach reso noto il la
versione italianizzata di tumblr
che la versione ristretta di
niubbi
che sarebbe
colui che appena iniziato a
giocare che corregge
daniel una live rotante ci
vogliono mesi a volte per
arrivarci
eppure lo dicono noi appena
iniziato giocate vale
il problema è che se noi siamo
delle debuttanti anche gli altri
purtroppo però censi come siamo
dosser verdi ci pensiamo uguale
-
per chi ha vissuto a livello di
armature e di equipaggiamenti di
armi
tu avevi collegare mature che
hai trovato nelle missioni
occhio perchè si è appena
arrivato quindi teoricamente
dovresti fare i primissimi
stanze con giocatori del tuo
stesso livello
perla aumentare
ce per aumentare il proprio
equipaggiamento
ovviamente no perchè io e
stefano de martino e risposta è
ovvia moto municipio
adele ad avere un personaggio
sole rosso primo personaggio che
ha messo una vita ad animare
livello 80
l'ho ovviamente
tutte le altre persone al quarto
quinto giocatore che vi quarto
quinto personaggio che facevo
quindi e dicevano
re qui
mheetu primo passaggio si lol
lol lol alla potestà di gruppo
con te nessuno storico po' con
noi
cagiva con quali regioni si
chiamava la mamma perché peso
neonato carrefour però è una
cosa che ci faceva ti incazzare
perchè
io più che mai abbiamo pensato
abbiamo appena iniziato c'è
easybook material 80
vogliamo fare le distanze ci
siamo capiti apposta non per
odio alimentazione gatti anche
per fare istanza oppo guerra
abbiamo mollato gioco perché
abbiamo fatti qualche stanza
ma pochi pulsanti
si crea un gruppo deve crearsi
radunarsi ci vogliono in quanto
dura 20 minuti prima di farmi
uscire a creare un gruppo di
gente per iniziare stanza
hey server crasha
qualcuno laggare pavia si
disconnetterà qualcuno gli cade
la connessione si disconette
esiderya avere tutte udah
rottura veramente
soprattutto se non sei normale
gita ci sono su imvu con i
giocatori
se sei da solo - 1 2
e' veramente tragico sei tutto
tempo in piazza a scrivere
convert from a scrivere chi c'è
per questi stanza vogliamo un
guerriero poliambulatorio bla
bla bla e poi non si arriva mai
a fare niente perché nessuno
giudice per fare cosa
è la prima istanza dovranno
essere lambertucci
tutti vogliono fare le stanze
più alte dopo 18 anni
quando inizia così avete uscita
in entrambe le gilde nessuno ci
voleva dicevo cosa fate questo
dai che lo sapevamo quella porta
dvd che vediamo anche no sissi
veniamo anche noi abbiamo
&lt cosa si vede che è che
chiude matura siete
questo qui il nolano e te lo
dice mamma giochiamo
ma queste sono problemino si
ripete un problema che ho
riscontrato io quindi ve lo dico
io nn ho giocati molti dicevano
che alcuni a pagamento che però
non mi piacevano esempio di
queste hey gioconda
ma i giochi con l
allora io scordata una grafica
come mass effect
pesantissima ma forse anche di
più ma proprio pesantissima
batman non perché i più
dettagliata di quelle di mass
effect mai perché il fatto
non piget fatto diversamente
avon sistema grafico
troppo troppo pesante c'è
troppo pesante
un esempio di queste cose
pratiche
se interrompo 2
se entro e' un gioco stupendo
è uscito per pc
qualcuno di voi ha provato la
versione per pc mi si intromette
impossibile da giocare in
possibile
a livello di dettaglio un minimo
che non ha una grafica tutta
nuda allucinante si
è buona ma come allucinante
party aska teacher gta 4 livello
vedo mi partiva bene se entro 2
parte marisa questo perché
cisti scuola materna grafica
questo che un gioco di ruolo
online ce dove ci sono
moltissimi giocatori
mutuo e una faticaccia ci
vediamo quando carica devi
aspettare che
vedo su tutta la grafica tutti i
colori perchè stupri giovedì
all'inizio emanata giglio
ehm
vedere questo ruolo paga con la
bellezza di un lemure 99
circa 39 euro e 90 unieuro a
d'amore
&lt di solito non pago per
giocare
era il giorno e mi da fastidio
pagare
per giocare ai giochi
perchè japan-guide internet e
pago gioco in cui far pagare
anche l'inter protesi
sono con sono così via
usiamo questo cuore per
woolworth e altre cose vengono
le carte prepagate da 60 giorni
se avete fatto le tenevo per
l'equivoco world mixer ma così
non 26 euro sito web 2 mesi 26
euro
sapete quanto costano le carte
prepagate tv il gioco numero
quattro libro dal pino scotto
costano la bellezza di un euro
99 ogni carta quindi ho preso
38 parte levopraid ora ho preso
il tuo 3 giusto per provare il
gioco
ho provato a video su berna
3 ore 3 4 ora quello
assolutamente mollato perchè
ce la facevo ci metterò trucco
poi
eurosport euro come modem router
le cimici giochi 5 minuti
polopoly
ci si può anche giocare cinese
come va bene perticolarmente
dire de valera - oppure muore
per giocare a una hai giù
qualche foto 4
roberto bolle hot
io poi
personalmente sono un patito
delle guide strategiche mi piace
un sacco anche i videogiochi che
non ho
l'incubo perché sono bellissimi
mi disegni di art book lema per
il emissioni ce
mi piace un sacco
eloro detto book celi solito non
le compro le compro quando
obliviscendum a 4 euro e 90
massimo roma eur e 90
ora sono la tua testo da dove
compra una carta prepagata
e ho visto c'era la guida tv
hey joe scuola bellissima
classical guitar che
dopo il dopo la prima volta
espansione
gratuita
era completamente inutile
perchè mancava un sacco di
dimissioni o sacco di marte ci
provi con quello presa perchè
mi piace
mi piace un sacco sfogliare
queste cose quindi se invece
capra
solo per vendetta chissà quanto
costo
secondo voi una guida strategica
che bobine costano 20 euro
20 15 euro 10 euro quando
scalano quattro alla volta
quando fanno le offerte massimo
secondo voi questa foto l'ho
pagata
20 euro
10 buone
5 nono non apri contattaci
pertanto mi serviva
no perchè domani veduto prende
la tre mi potevo perdermi un
panino con 3 1
un euro
no troppo 50 centesimi -
trenta sicli
10 centesimi
5 centesimi
gioco
tre centimetri no
delussu romanzi vado a prenderlo
scontrino più opportuna
bacchettone. immagini telefilm
è un fucile tra
oh happy su onlus. comprato una
guida strategica di un gioco
aucun sintesi love giusto se fai
pagare il gioco
unieuro 99 la guida cella
guidate di scalare in base al
prezzo di costo cuccette rivolta
sul web non so se riuscite
elettrici scritto
ho creduto guida e il suo
con matteo gioconda
total euro
0 , 0 1
contate e io doppio zero, si
cucinano anche da
felicidad
quindi secondo me lo sono
inventato un centesimo una guida
strategica
è impazzito quel giorno vorrei
dire una cosa e poi chiudo con i
videogiochi
questo è una cosa generale
inside joke ma soprattutto si
ride giochino agevolazione
presepio
crediamo modern warfer 2
custodia normalissima
è normale
manuale cervice calde coppie
sottile manuale se non sapete
cosa serve ti spiega
solite cose cuneo
nel me installare il gioco bocce
a quale 2010 ti stimo come
installare gioco i tasti
ti spiegherò con procura
paginetta di
d link informazioni del
della schermata di quando giochi
cilmi vino bricofer in bianco e
nero ep 4 ma non mi ha anche
preso immagini di gioco ce lo
scrivo qua il grigio non è
perchè voi non riuscite a
vedere
e' proprio grigio
qualche informazione su minore
quelle classiche cose che fb spa
attenzione a non bagnare di
sketch effect solo 4 pagine
60 euro per un gioco ci sono
quattro pagine di manuale
pregnant nude for peta
apro le fucked
tvb codice per istallare gioco
è niente male ma non perchè me
l'hanno venduto usato nuovo
preso nuovo
non c'è manuale
io odio i giochi nuovi
perchè non vedi mettere il
manuale del doping
dentro la custode del gioko
tupac in gioco 60 euro dentro ci
deve essere tutto secondo me
c'è una cosa
nella confezione
e' come quando ti faccio un
regalo se loro sicuro ti regala
pietro conatti tico tacos itc
tieni questo è il regalo
così contento perché i
genitori giocone ma da una parte
dal buio della potestà tizio
peccato però che non era
confezionato bene
certissimo confeziona per un
regalo con la carte tutori
legali ancora più bello
anche se cade sempre lo stesso
però il regalo della cosa ti
stimo molto più veloce il la
carta scartarlo il bigliettino
con scritto gli auguri per pc
ed. che bello
stessa cosa del gioco si è
spento
non è questo caldo direttore di
genova 60 euro per un gioco
elenco non c'è assolutamente
nulla oltre il dvd di gioco
incasso un pò
ma un po'
ma perchè
perchè io parlo dei giochi
quelli vecchi c'è accordi o no
il primo uomo tua cartella
custode quegli occhi
la5 xd
è un po' scomodo effettivamente
però
5 siti web
prof guardate cosa ce l'ha detto
oltre ciao un catalogo dei
prodotti
nella vita
il manuale
guardate quote spesso fa male
c'è un libro re
università e si è lamentata
per questo iphone no comment
libro come formattare pc da ce
storie di qualsiasi cosa
schermate di personaggi
essi in una ragazza per tutti i
miei parco di patty addirittura
levante
del gioco il capo e nero e ma
perchè facebook c'avevo
per la prostituta che si
trasformano alcune ore
carlo studio di qualsiasi cosa
classi razze c tutto io le adoro
queste cose con codice
del gioco -
in queste cose impazzisco quando
vedo delle cose così e' pieno
pieno pieno pieno di roma
a me piacciono queste cose non
vedo perchè non vedo non fai
più
i fatti degli altri
in quelli nuovi c'è il video di
denti dvd di gioco
poi mammole tutte colissimo devi
spiegare classiche cose come
istallare gioco le cose che odio
ti odio ti odio queste cose
ma presepio
ho comprato ho pochissimo ma
proprio pochissimo prezzo non so
perchè stanno impazzendo
lecce compro tutto a pochissimo
prezzo perchè
nei negozi dicono che gamestop o
detto ma scusate quagliarella la
guida di gioco nel sito
impazziti costa un centesimo mai
avere fascisti è vero
the per pc nessuno + compralo
all'asta poste vendo tutto
merda mare
boh per me ma male perchè poi
non ci vanno più esclusive per
pc marocco
questo pacchetto pochissime la
black box della via della sigla
eidos non ci sono nuovi giochi
dentro me
petite robe nero sono stati
parecchi di questi fate
cheese calcetto
crisi taxi c'è tomb raider che
fa schifo photobomber cerca e me
capì fecero auto travolge un
gran bel gioco commandos 3
cambiando il gioco the sims
deluxe egli desidera
per battelfield vietnam
mosse volte di chi è bellissima
e pacifico assolte non medal of
honor pacific assault volte
io mi son chiesto
come si fa a stare delle custode
del genere
perchè secondo voi questo ci
potrebbe stare
in un uomo solo mettendomi
giochi
pur crema di buste certo
2 agosto comprare una scatola
con un giochi così
c'è tanto vale che badoo
la bancarella di
qualcuno di alda catone live
oppure faccio comprare
masterizzata betshop erbe
poi certo
ma devo portare la sua del 900
parte che non c'è nessun
poggetto dentro i codici dei
giochi software sulla scatola
sulla scatola direttamente
all'interno della scatola
la turchia dentro l'altra
ma non tutte le tope
beh e va be'
la questo l'hanno fatto per
problemi di spazio mettere la la
carta
many man man ci stavano. sapete
cosa ho fatto a letto
manuale di questi giochi c'erano
tutti
ma non lasciamoci tale che dice
cosa che ho fatto
un dvd con scritto the better
box e dice un pc collection
manuale ma dove vai
non so parlar d'altro e dintorni
scaricato anche questa è vita
in che senso ha fare un cd
corrimano argomenti le ho mai
detto di riposo legge che
manuale manu
ambiente se lo devo leggere dvd
che senso fa
tanto non so se un solo problema
mio ma questi giochi
quando installo
mi dice poi inserire dvd
cornetto quindi io potevo
scaricare la crack
metterla nel un gioco originale
perchè non so perchè forse
perché sono vecchi
ma non così tanto ci sono tutti
compatibili con wii speak
quando io li metto lista o
gruppo non posso giocarci con
questo tipo di donne che si apra
tanto vale che me li compro
masterizzati che problema è
questo
io ho finito
scusatemi se di dove era molto
lungo perdonatemi se volete con
la funzione undo importante
e scusate se i super veloce
nonostante sia abbastanza busty
super veloce per fiere
non ho tempo di montalcino tutto
non ho trovato immagini
e quindi niente sky si vede alla
un
premiazione del
del concorso
sono felice di fare nuovo già
fatto la lista petrovafire la
lista dei
possibili candidati alla finale
sono
13 gennaio su come scegliere un
pub e ne parlero' polpette
siete tutti sullo stesso livello
quindi dovrai scegliere delle
motivazioni stupide per torte
vince per decretare il vincitore
dove siete delle votazioni
superato degli altri però mi
spiace. ne parlerò cui al
concorso ci siete il 20 marzo